on this episode I'm in a good mood
because the Jets crushed the Dolphins
and we go on an epic rant at the end of
the show around the inflection point
[Music]
this is
Gary B everybody this is gary
vay-ner-chuk and this is episode 1 67 of
the ask gary vee show i'm in a very good
mood the jets one that is good you're in
a bad mood
cuz Kobe's retiring that's something
like that's like a humble brag oh I'm
really sad cuz a guy that won me five
world championships is finally 40 years
old and retiring I understand you grew
up with him but you know like sports it
should be pretty simple it's like can
you win did you lose you won with Kobe I
know it's sad and emotional but you'll
be fine
India you did a surprise trip to us
after you said here on the show that you
were not going anywhere you went to San
Francisco that was good you had a good
Thanksgiving
you Rock everybody here's the
vaynermedia employee joining us good
Thanksgiving once you tell the
vaynernation a little bit about what you
do here and things of that nature
sure I'm sure here's my line Instagram I
on our team and so lovin it go well it's
amazing
very good how long have you been at
Vayner almost a year and a half out of
college straight out of college
yeah so I'm gonna good mood no salty
Monday and now we have an entire week
I'm here this week so we'll have a lot
of shows the build-up will be extreme
for the battle for New York the Jets
versus the Giants both teams seasons on
the lines a little bit less for the
Giants because their division is so bad
but it's going to be a huge game it is
going to be raucous I'm going to
actually make a real commitment to a
substantial snapchat story of my
experience this weekend going to that
jets-giants game I as a Jets fan clearly
the team that's won less in New York
Giants have won four Super Bowls in my
mouth I've won I've been to none
during my fandom we are clearly the
little brother in town we do have that
chip on our shoulder this is a very big
game for me I'm quite emotional about it
I
sited and I you know I jumped off the
bandwagon of making predictions the Jets
played much better than I expected
yesterday I'm probably not gonna make a
prediction because now I'm gonna go with
a suit you know worked so we'll go with
that route but I will talk quite about a
big about it and all you giant fans this
will be good let's just are we taping
the show on Friday I think we are right
all you giant fans please go on
Instagram make your 15-second trash-talk
videos to me for this game let's really
get the juices going for this game
because I am fired up for it I'm fired
up for it in 1988 we knocked the Giants
out of the playoffs in the last game of
the year that was awesome in 1993 when I
was a senior in high school we beat the
Giants since then it's not been going as
well and so I'd like to get back in the
wing column India with that I would like
to get into the show
Matthew Oh before I get into the show I
would also like to say that I hope
everybody had a wonderful Thanksgiving
it's great time I feel like Thanksgiving
is one of the real great vacations of
all time you know that kind of really
starts on Tuesday people kind of travel
on Wednesday for me there's nothing like
that Wednesday when I know everybody's
checked out it's like really like
Wednesday night Thursday night Friday
night Saturday night all quite relaxing
and I really enjoyed it an amazing time
with my family and so I hope you did it
as well now I am ready to get into the
show Matt says the golf coaching world
has been boring for way too long
what would a scary V do to create a bad
at golf coaching business
well Golf is boring so wait Matthew
starts with golf coaching got it no look
I mean every world is boring in a lot of
ways outside of heavy entertainment
genres or high-energy genres until a
personality comes along I would say for
the common American financing and
finance news was boring until Jim Cramer
came along I take a lot of pride in the
fact that a lot of people through the
years tens of them
maybe hundreds of thousands have told me
that wine was boring until I came along
and so you're always one personality
away you know Howard Cosell changed
sports casting I think you're one a
extreme high-energy entertaining person
away from changing an entire culture and
so this is quite basic I mean you know
to me anytime something becomes exciting
it's on the back of a human being making
it exciting and so you know you know
Emeril Lagasse made chef culture you
know less boring by saying bow or
whatever he did right and that was in
the early 90s so I the answer to your
question is and I assume you're alluding
this way Matthew listen now if you've
got the chops if you've got the charisma
if you're entertaining enough then you
will be that person and I think that's
an important thing for everybody
understand you know everything is based
and predicated on the actions you know
everybody wants to change you know my
tagline on Wine Library TV uses we're
changing the wine world whether they
like it or not caught a lot of people's
attention it brings a lot of people
coming to me around this question you
know if you your actions have to
represent the thing that you want to
happen and so please anybody who's
trying to change the hair extension
world or the art world or the music
world or you know whatever the making
apps the I feel like whatever thing
you're trying to change
you're either changing it or you're not
your actions are creating your change
and so when I hear that question if
you're not putting out the content
that's compelling and entertaining
experience well then there's no talking
about it like if you've been doing it
then it's happening and if you're not
doing it it's not happening and saying
that you're gonna do it or asking me to
for the answer to it it's just the
action since every single boring world
can be changed science there's people
that make science interesting and
literature interesting like it's out
there like levar burton meet reading
interesting with his rainbow I mean like
you know anybody can do it so that's the
answer it's just a human being coming
along and being entertaining within the
genre and having the expert
to not have the experts laugh them off
the stage and make it seem like they're
a comedian just doing that and I think
that's what it comes down to the equal
parts you actually know what the hell
you're talking about with golf lessons
and golf culture and really no golf and
can really teach and then you're also
ridiculously handsome and charismatic to
execute that entertainment factor
Anastasia Anastasia asked in the age of
screen shot repost on social I liked
screen shots I just like them I just
like you to know that I like them okay
how do you see brands protecting
themselves do we say goodbye to
copyrights
listen copyright is on on as on watch
right like copy Inc copyrights been put
on shade like it needs to understand
like stuff like it is being trolled like
yeah I mean like an on the flip side
like there's a lot of push the other way
but yes I mean like we're not in you
know we're not in the same world as we
used to be anymore technology has
created this scenario where we all
collectively have to figure this out I
mean like music was put on blast by
Napster and then like we had a whole
decade or two of innovation Apple came
along figured out how to make it
compelling YouTube you know came along
found out how to make a compelling
overtime at first it was not as
compelling to the copyright people yeah
I think listen we will never fully get
away from where somebody creates
something that they're not being
compensated I don't think we're too far
down the culture of that on the flip
side you know it's a it's a it's a rub
because the truth is a lot of people
want people to use their stuff they want
both they want both right they want to
use you want them to use your music or
picture in the commercial so you get
commercial success but you want to be
compensated for that the truth is
there's so much content and so many
things that can be used that
alternatives of things that are free are
becoming more and more of the of the fad
I think that much like we answered the
Adele question which worked out for her
I think you know I think we use Sh'ma
del and I think this was three or four
episodes ago I think every person who's
watching and listening needs to make a
decision for themselves if they're
better off you letting people use their
stuff or not I watch people use my
imagery all the time somebody made a
salt EVP shirt on P public the team hit
me up they're like what do we do do we
want to take it out I decided no that's
in my benefit that if people buy that I
won't make the 18 cents or $4 or
whatever it is pressure that's okay
because it's valuable for me at this
moment on the flip side people use my
image to sell like [ __ ] like
information products where like I don't
believe in it that's bad
I do try tell them to take that down
that's a copyright issue because that's
falsely making it look like I'm
endorsing some [ __ ] $300 ebook or
course so I think you have to make an
individual investment weigh the value
props you know there was a vine for I
brought this up before where the girl
used a booty shaking song in her
twerking video that made that song shoot
up it was like 10 years old shoot up to
number 10 in the iTunes store if they
would have taken that down they would
have missed out on all the sales of the
album which they made money on so you've
got to be strategic in this new world
it's not a one-size-fits-all kind of an
answer we looking at India okay well I
could tell there's nothing super
interesting going on back I agree just
peeps Maddie Matt says Richard Branson
says clients do not come first employees
come first do you agree or disagree and
why I agree and Matt Matt that I mean I
agree and like I've been pounding that
you know that for 166 episodes so at
least 40 times so I feel very
comfortable and kind of dodging this
answer because I think one of the things
like the repetitiveness of this show is
something I challenge myself with always
recognizing there's so many new people
watching ahead you know and there's a
lot of people watching so I'll just go
very fast this doesn't get my juices
going and I'm not trying to diss Matt it
I assume you're fairly new so
excited it's not even close to me it is
fundamentally my employees then my
customers that my own interests and that
has been the backbone of my success I
feel like you end up with a whole lot if
you go in that order and I think my
actions have spoken to that at this
company I've got a lot of people that
have worked in the agency industry for a
long time and have been surprised by how
hard I push back on clients we've fired
a client historically which is sacrilege
even though people say it and so yes I
think Richards correct and I think
anybody's successful like a Branson
that's built an actual organization not
as like a single entertainer as an
investor or somebody built a product
somebody that actually built a six
hundred a six thousand a sixty thousand
person organization or a six person
organization successfully recognizes how
much value in the people there really is
I also happen to like people which makes
it even easier for me so just keeping it
very basic I say I say yes I'm curious
to your strategy of picking that
question India fine come with real data
and answers in the know really good job
yes so now that India's guilted me into
going a little bit deeper here no no
listen I mean I appreciate it I'll go a
little bit even further
to me it's a very big deal and and and
it's so surprising to me
law firms consultants agencies where
they actually sell people's hours that
they're not completely infatuated with
that process I get it for Wine Library
where like we were selling wine the end
result was a transaction with wine the
end result here is a transaction with
another human being against their ours
so again if you are in a business where
that is the case you you run multiple
gyms and you have trainers you you know
you again law firm consultants anybody
who's listening to this who has a
business that people's hours are being
sold should be religious I mean coldish
about caring about their people and then
anybody that's selling a byproduct of it
you're probably your results are gonna
the shelves are gonna be stocked better
at Wine Library you're gonna get a
better answer on a recommendation from
Wine Library if you care about your
people even though the end result
product is a bottle of wine or if you go
into a bicycle shop the end result is
still selling a bike but if Ricci is
happy when he came into the shop and you
come in for a bike he's gonna spend that
extra 15 minutes enthusing
enthusiastically trying to tell you that
this tire is better than that tire that
[ __ ] matters
Jacob asks would Gary take 20 minutes
out of his day to watch askgaryvee no I
would not watch the show I know I've
lost viewers because of this answer I've
watched that have happened
I've actually been curious because
there's been like 10 or 11 people in
fatica Lee saying I'm not watching
anymore because you I get it like and
then I kind of like follow like I tagged
them and I kind of like follow up and
I'm like oh crap I really lost them
which makes me happy and sad but I mean
II sure used to do that my daughter's to
do that she's like I'm happy and sad and
so that's where that came from and so
the answer is I wouldn't because it's
not how I roll but I also would have
never watched one episode so I think
that's an important thing for the people
listening and watching like the way I
learn is different the way I do things
is different and there's no right or
wrong as a matter of fact my biggest
issue is that I wish I had a little bit
of more of that in me you know I wish
that I would you know read a book or two
here and there or like I wish I consumed
people's content that I was aligned with
or can learn from it's just
I'm just too into the Anthropology of
just watching like after the Knicks game
last night tough double and tough
overtime loss to the Rockets Michael
Lang if you're watching screw you I mean
I spent all my time watching everybody
on their phones and by the way it was an
Instagram snapchat only world from 16 to
46 New York route but super fascinating
so that's how I learned I learned by
watching I learned by watching all of
your behaviors in the comments and then
seeing what you do I learned by all of
you being so honest about tell me your
truth learned a lot about a lot of you
individually helps me interact with you
so that I'm on that side of the coin so
answer's no I would not watch the show
Malik not Malik Sealy none of you know
who Malik Caelius oh let's go basketball
player played for your favorite teams I
think he went to Syracuse or st. John's
definitely a local school I think st.
John I'm gonna pretend that it's Malik
Sealy Wow Malik thanks for watching the
show man I was a big fan of your college
career
Malik ass what advice do you have for
someone who finds out that they're not
cut out to be an entrepreneur oh yeah I
get it Malik coz you believed I'm just
being an entrepreneur is not some great
like thing like it's just as good as
being anything it's just as good as
being a great I mean you know listen as
much as it's amazing for me that I
inspire people to maybe build businesses
that then is a gateway drug to happiness
in their life I mean I feel really
compelled to be financially secure have
better work/life balance and be a brain
surgeon and save people's lives on a
daily basis like like there's a lot of
thing or like simple things like do you
know you know maybe not as financially
rewarding but if you're wired to be a
great guidance counselor like impacting
teenagers through those really difficult
being a guidance counselor in high
school for real like and if you're not
mailing it in and full of [ __ ] and only
one Oh be there 93 like you're how like
if you really are in it it just comes
out and you know it's funny
so that would be cool to be a guidance
counselor which leads me the point or
made me think of this which is if you're
if you're really passionate and I don't
use that word as you guys know like I
kind of stay away from that because I
think it's a kind of a [ __ ] E word
but if you're truly passionate and
really into what you do and you really
give it your all like if you really do
whether you do it for yourself or within
an organization that you believe in or
within an organization that you think
will get you to the place you want to be
one day which is really what I try to
build here which is one of those two
things right it's a place you want to be
around me and that energy and that
success and that machine for the rest of
your life or you feel like the things
you learn at Bain are over a 2 6 12 19
year career only lends itself to the
things you want to do in the future if
you're lucky enough to be an
those scenarios regardless of what you
do if you like passionately get up in
the morning if you got up this morning
at 6 a.m. like I did and we're fired up
to go of course because the Jets won but
fired up to go and you're to go was
you're gonna go in the office and from
9:00 to 4:00 you're gonna clean teeth
and work on cavities cuz you're a badass
mother dentist that loves the teeth game
well then you've won like like you know
my advice is if you figured out you
weren't an entrepreneur well then you're
just like one of those contestants on
American Idol that like went there he
gave him that back good for you kudos
you stood in front of Simon and he said
you stink and you're like crap and then
you went home and it aired a couple
months later and everybody laughed at
you and I'm twittered I said you stunk
and you're like alright maybe I mean you
know we're done maybe I can't sing now
what you need to do is comma move on and
try to figure out what you can do what
you are good at and more importantly
what do you love and then there's the
other big semicolon I don't even know
that's definitely not the proper grammar
but like there's the other parallel
thing which is like you don't give a
crap that you suck at singing you can't
breathe and believe that you could do
anything else you're just gonna sing
awesome go get a job at like a karaoke
bar like go like work at a music store
and just sit there and all day and say
like there's absolutely this remarkable
balance of what makes you happy what
makes you the most money some people are
just blessed lucky or or grinded their
way into it or we're born with the
talent of like being able to do both I
would tell you that if I could make
enough money to make me happy uh because
I want it because I like it I like the
game it's the game of it more so than it
but like go wrong I've often thought
about fully retiring and just garage
saling you know I but the problem is I
just have too much other ambition and
other things I want to do and it's
really not predicated on the money but
like the girl like I'm very close
I'm one DNA strand away from being a guy
that makes eighty seven thousand dollars
a year of garage selling every day and
that's cool and like I have so many
friends and relatives that are ripped
crap happy that tried to be
entrepreneurs failed just like I would
fail to be a professional hockey player
or
singer and have gone on to massively
happy like it's just about being happy
and so my advice for an entrepreneur
would be you know dust it off be like
alright That's not me
even though it's a hot thing to be right
now let me go figure out what I can do
that is to me the magic is what's the
thing that you can do the best that you
like the most what's that cross-section
and that's a great place to be right it
may not be perfect you might not be like
Kobe who loves playing like you could
see in his face loves playing basketball
more than breathing and happen to be
phenomenal at it which is why you become
Kobe look like like there's a reason
there's Kobe there's a reason there's
Madonna there's a reason that there are
these one names of people like cher you
know like like like there's a reason
like like like let's cut to the chase
because they happen to have at the
inflection point the passion and love
and desire and the talent for that thing
and found that thing which is a whole
nother category of things to be
successful I feel like I've had that but
I also recognize in so many not that
exact thing or the upper-middle class
version of it the eight on a 10-point
scale that's seven point to the nine
point one the five point four it's just
you know that's what you're looking for
you know that's what you're looking for
and then there's the balance of risk and
practicality so many people are not born
with the risk gene of an entrepreneur
you're just not willing to take the
chance it's just too scary I just don't
know the other way it was too scary not
to get F's for me I've always fought the
system I can't conform to what people
think is right it's just not how I see
the world it's just not what I see so I
think tripling down on you if you found
out you're not entrepreneur you probably
weren't self aware to begin with to
realize that you weren't gonna win in
that anyway you're probably just
following a narrative of what's sexy or
what's attractive and you think a big
big boy big girl step back in your life
and say okay let's get really real with
ourselves what is the thing I'm best at
that I like the most and then
triple down on that put yourself in that
position quit your job or quit the
failed startup and go start you know
whittling wood because it might just be
great at it and you can sell the damn
little statues in an amazing Museum shop
in Wyoming be happy as goddamn he'll
make a good buck your one Instagram
photo away from somebody saying look how
amazing this is
now you're the wood Wetterling or for
the celebrities and like I mean this is
real you know but this is real like this
is how [ __ ] goes down and it's funny and
I know it's a funny I'm glad I got you
India but like like what do you think
happened with DJ's like they just loved
it so much and so they made five hundred
bucks on the side of parties deejay am
like I watched Doc you and then he
became the one that did it for Madonna's
parties and then he got paid a million
dollars to be the DJ in residence in
Vegas like funny things happen when
triple down on your strengths a lot of
times the world comes to you a lot of
times the world comes to you it may not
seem like you can make them too many
people like I'm awesome at this and I
love this but it doesn't make a lot of
money mmm I hate that because that is
the place to go cuz all of a sudden the
world comes to you
1979 I'm a great chef and I love cooking
more than life but I'm not gonna be a
chef because it only pays fifty thousand
dollars at this restaurant and I'm the
help yeah until that twenty two-year-old
then in 1995 is 37 and that celebrity
chefs are now a thing and she has her
own show I mean like that's what I think
cool that was fun that was fun to be in
that bubble for a second oh we still
have a podcast question okay thank you
for everybody who's been watching uh and
I will close the show right now and then
we'll do a podcast thing question of the
day you know what what is that
inflection point for you right now we've
been very truthful I like it let's go
there right now
tell me your inflection point the thing
you like the most that you're the best
at I just want to know what that thing
is and then as a little context play for
me , are you actually doing that or are
you right now being practical paying
back loans you make 200,000 being a
lawyer so you
do that thing because that would only
make 50k what is your inflection point
you keep asking questions I'll keep
answering them
[Music]